Hello everybody and welcome to another
moneymaking guide. Today I'm going to be
showing you something kind of cool I
found um just the other day and that is
going to be repairing Barrows items for
profit. And by what I mean by that is
we're going to be buying uh totally used
up Barrows items, repairing them and
selling them back on the Grand Exchange
for pretty decent amounts of profit. Uh
now these items do buy pretty slowly,
but we're going to put some offers in
overnight and just show you how much uh
you could expect to make uh if you just
leave these offers in for I don't know
12 15 hours just overnight or while
you're doing something. And yeah, let's
get started.
Okay, so to start off, I'm going to be
showing you how to uh calculate the
items margin to begin with. Uh so then
we can go on and find which bear items
might work best for doing this repair uh
moneymaking technique. Uh so to start
off, we'll just get GE Tracker open. So
I'll be using this for most of the uh
moneymaking guide. Um but you can use RS
Buddy or whatever you like to use, but
you it'll be handy to have a website
that's going to track the prices for
you. So now to uh do this here, so
here's actually a spreadsheet of all the
Barrows items right now. Um but if you
don't have access to this, what you're
going to do is you're going to take the
price of the uh repaired Barrows item.
uh you're going to subtract off um the
price of the barrows items O and then
we'll go have a quick look here. Barrows
items
repair cost and then there's going to be
a different cost based on what piece of
equipment it is. Um and this is assuming
you're using NPC to repair the
equipment. If you own or have level 41
uh construction, you can make an armor
stand and then it'll be based off your
smithing level. Uh, but here are the
base costs of the barrels repair. Helm
is 60,000, body is 90,000, legs 80,000,
and the weapon is 100,000. So, we'll do
a quick calculation here for you. Um, so
say the Gthan's helm. So, we'll start
off by looking up the Gthan's helm.
Uh, we want the Gthan's helm O as well
as uh the Gthins helm
uh repaired essentially.
And uh so the Guffins Helm O doesn't
trade a whole lot, but you would still
be able to snag it for a decent price.
We're going to come down here to the
most recent data possible. Um 34.90
possibly is what we could buy it for,
but the highest buy price, 3567.
We'll just take this approximate offer
price of 3567. So that's going to be the
price we're going to be buying the item
at. So essentially your buy offer uh
what we're going to be selling it for.
Let's just take this number here. Get
the calculator open.
So 3782
is what we're going to be selling our
finished product for. Going to take off
3567.
And then on top of that, it's going to
cost 100k to repair. So that would leave
us with 115k in profit on this item. And
uh this technique is pretty safe. You
just have to put an offer in for
something that won't lose you money
essentially. So, if you put an offer in
for well 3567,
uh unless this item crashes, um you will
pretty much be safely making money
assuming you actually buy the item. And
this works for all different types of
bears equipment. Just keep in mind that
the cost repair does vary based on um if
you have a construction level and what
piece of equipment it is. Okay, so we
have a short list of items here um that
I think might be pretty profitable to
repair. Uh, so we're going to start with
the cheaper of the items, the Krill's
leather top, which I have brought up
here already, I think. Uh, Krill's
leather skirt. Sorry. Uh, so it's the
cheaper of the items here. So, we're
basically going to come down uh to the
price. We're going to go down to the
cheapest of the most current data here.
Um, and we'll put a buy offer in for
probably 211. I think that's the best.
211. Yeah. And uh if we come over and
look at the krills
leather skirt repaired.
Let's do one more example here. Then
I'll kind of run through the other ones
quickly. I can see it sells for 353.
Uh at least as of the current prices.
Might even be able to get a little bit
more for that. Um but 353. So we'll go
calculate that here. 353
minus 210
and the cost of repairing this item is I
don't know it says over here actually
80,000 which is correct legs 80,000 so
we'll take 80k off of that as well
looking to get 63 on each repair if we
bought five of those that's 300k it's
pretty cheap item too for the amount of
money we're getting back okay so Krill's
leather skirt going to put an offer in
for 211 I think leather skir 0
211k
and uh we'll do five of these maybe.
Yeah, see that's only 1 mil. That's not
a whole lot invested. So we'll do five
or six. Sure. Whatever. Too lazy to hit
the down button. So Gthan's chain skirt
is the next one I want to try.
Uh 451. We're going to come over here,
which is actually the list of the items.
Now it's a pretty nice feature of G
Tracker. Uh but again, it's not vital by
any means. Gothan's chain skirt here. It
looks like we could sell them for 609
approximately. All right, so the
Gothin's chain skirt zero will put an
offer in for 451k.
And we'll do four of these maybe.
Sure, four. Um, moving on to the next
item here. Uh, we'll do the more
expensive, uh, Verac's plate skirt.
So, let's have a quick look here.
Brock's plate skirt is about 1.5 mil. Go
look up the Verac
plate skirt zero.
Uh, so we could hopefully sell it for
roughly
1.66 mil and we're looking to Well,
that's definitely not the right one. Uh,
looking to buy it for$,450
approximately. All right. And the last
item I think we're actually going to end
up doing is the Guth helm empty. Uh, so
we're going to put an offer in for 35 at
68.
Then I think we're going to go to bed.
Gotham's helm zero. 3568K.
Actually, you know what? We're going to
put it actually in for the actively last
sold price, which is actually 34.90.
Let's just do 3500. Even 3500K.
Uh,
oops. 3500.
And we'll just do two. little bit of
money left over. And yeah, guys, we'll
come back in the morning and see what we
managed to buy. All right, it is the
following morning and I woke up so damn
sick. So, we're going to get this video
over with and I'm going to go make some
eggs and toast and some tea. So, let's
get this done. Uh the Verox plate
skirts, we bought all of all five. Um
the Gthins chain skirt, we got all four
of them, so pretty good. Um Guffins
helm, we did get the two we wanted. Um,
the Krill leather skirt. We only got
two. Uh, but that's okay. So, now all we
have to do is we're going to go to I
guess Lumbridge will be the closest.
Um, I think you're going to have to
unnote them first. So, we'll come here.
Should just withdraw them
and just withdraw them without any
notations on them.
after teleporting to Lumbridge. Is this
this guy down here? For some reason,
Bob's axe shop is the guy who repairs
this legendary armor. Okay, so over at
Bob, you can hit the repair button.
And for all the items, it's going to be
1 mil because there's five legs.
Six, seven legs actually. Quite almost
all legs pretty much. I'm sure this is
right though. So, we'll go ahead and
repair all the items for 1 mil.
And there we go. Everything has been
repaired. We can go and sell it back on
the Grand Exchange. 1610K. How about
all five of those?
Okay, so we actually instantly sold
that.
Whoops. Okay, so next up we have the
Guth chain skirt. Uh, which looks like
we can sell roughly 608k.
Gothan's chain skirt.
60 to 607k.
And do all of those. Okay. And the next
item we're doing is a krill's leather
skirt. Yeah, leather skirt. Uh, which we
should sell for 332k.
Roughly.
[Music]
332k.
do all of those. See if we can sell that
or not. No. And last up is the Gthan's
helm. And the Gthan's helm we can sell
for uh 36
68. How about
68k? We might be underdoing this a
little bit. Um but we just kind of want
these items to sell. And there we go.
We'll come back when the items have
totally sold.
All right, guys. So, they totally sold.
Um, mind you, we sold half of them
instantly. Kind of by accident, kind of
not. Um, so yeah, we'll claim all of
this and we'll see how much money we
ended up making. Uh, so taking all this
into account. We'll break down the
individual profits afterwards.
Okay, mind you, we started with about 20
mil. And by about, I mean exactly.
and we're going to finish with about
900k in profit. Uh so not bad.
Okay, so now just to break down quickly
uh what items did the best and the
frocks play skirt definitely gave us the
best profit. Uh we sold it for 8083K and
we bought it for uh 7255.
That gives us uh 828k minus 400k to
repair the item. Leaves us with 428k in
profit. Pretty good for the rocks plate
skirt. And I think they bought the
cookus too. Uh the Guth chain skirt we
sold for 2434
and uh we bought it for 1812. That
leaves us with 622k minus 320k to repair
the item is 302k in profit.
Uh the helm was okay. We still made a
decent profit on it. We sold it for uh
7136.
That's what we bought it for. 7136
and we sold it for 7343. That leaves us
with 27K. Uh minus 120K to repair both
the helmets leaves us with 87K in
profit. Uh the Krill leather skirt we
bought for 422K
and uh we sold it for 664K.
That leaves us with 242K minus 160 gives
us 82K in profit. In total, that leaves
us with about 900k in profit.
Very low risk, easy way uh to make a
good amount of money. I just left it in
overnight and woke up, sold the sold in
like 10 minutes. And that's it, guys. I
hope you enjoyed and I'll see you guys
in the next episode.
[Music]